aux etats unis à présent le docteur
anthony fauci dans la tourmente depuis
la publication de milliers de ces
correspondances le monsieur santé des
maisons blanches est la cible des
critiques des républicains pour plus de
précisions nous retrouvons tout de suite
notre reporter thomas bonnin en direct
de washington
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir touba merci d'être avec
nous qu est-il précisément reproché au
docteur phau 6 eh bien depuis la
diffusion de milliers de ces courriels
il lui est notamment reproché un écart
entre ses prises de position publiques
et ses conversations privées et
notamment l'exemple du port du masque
puisqu'ils et il ya un mail qui est
apparu dans la diffusion donc qui a été
fait la semaine dernière qui date du 5
février 2020 et dans lequel anthony
faute qui explique que le port du masque
n'est pas encore recommander n'est pas
recommandable en tout cas la personne
qui lui adresse e mail à l'époque il
explique que le masque permet d'empêcher
la propagation du virus pour les
personnes qui sont infectées mais ne
protège pas les personnes qui ne sont
pas malades alors il dit que depuis
évidemment les connaissances ont évolué
et on comprend aussi en filigrane qu'à
l'époque un peu comme en france il n'y
avait de toute façon pas suffisamment de
masques pour l'ensemble de la population
américaine
autre point qui a retenu l'attention
justement dans la diffusion de ses mails
sur l'origine du virus puisque certains
échanges évoque cette possibilité d'un
virus qui serait fabriqué en laboratoire
une hypothèse qui a pourtant toujours
été écartée par le docteur anthony fauci
même si récemment depuis récemment il a
un petit peu changé son fusil d'épaulé
maintenant cette hypothèse n'est plus
complètement écarté il ya même des
investigations qui ont été demandés par
joe biden justement sur l'origine du coc
vite 19 en tout cas beaucoup demandent
des explications sur ce changement de
discours entre les mails d'anthony faute
si et ses prises de parole publiques
il se défend ce moment il fait un peu la
tournée des médias notamment répondu à
une interview sur la chaîne
ms nbc et vous propose d'écouter cet
extrait ce que vous voyez sont des
accusations très dangereuse ce sont des
attaques directes contre moi et contre
la science
parce que tout ce que j'ai dit depuis le
début est fondamentalement basé sur la
science
vous avez entendu cette phrase
s'attaquer à moi c'est s'attaquer à la
science et cette phrase a évidemment
provoqué beaucoup de réactions ici aux
etats unis parce que d'une certaine
manière certains y ont vu une forme
d'arrogance de la part d' anthony fochi
et puis surtout en disant que s'attaquer
à lui c'est s'attaquer à la science le
scientifique empêche toute forme de
critique contre son travail qu'il a
effectuée depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois
antoine est fatigué aussi devenu la
cible de critiques de certains élus
républicains
oui c'est devenu très politique c'est
une affaire qui est devenu très
politique beaucoup de critiques contre
lui pas seulement donc sur les
contradictions que vous exposez il ya
quelques instants mais aussi sur sa
relation avec facebook par exemple des
élus républicains ont adressé une lettre
ce mercredi à mark zuckerberg le pdg de
facebook qui lui demande tout simplement
de dévoiler l'intégralité de ses
correspondances avec anthony faute si
parce qu'il soupçonne le scientifique
d'avoir pu influencer d'une manière ou
d'une autre la politique de facebook en
matière de censure de contenus
concernant la thèse donc d'un virus
fabriquer en laboratoire parce que dans
les échanges qui ont été diffusées la
semaine dernière il y à une
correspondance entre zuckerberg est faux
tickets a été publié le pdg de facebook
demande aux scientifiques s'il serait
d'accord pour participer à une campagne
de prévention sur le kobe 19 notamment
par le biais d'une vidéo de questions
réponses les républicains en tout cas
certains élus républicains veulent donc
maintenant savoir jusqu'où se sont
établis les liens entre le scientifique
de la maison blanche et le patron de
facebook et puis plus généralement faute
si devenue aujourd'hui la cible
privilégiée des républicains à commencer
par l'ancien président des états unis
donald trump qui a eu anthony fauci
comme conseiller à la maison blanche
pendant plusieurs mois on sait que les
rapports entre les deux hommes étaient
parfois très compliqué
preuve une fois de plus lors du discours
de donald trump ce week-end en caroline
du nord écoutez pas aussi a dis avec
force au début pas de masque pas de
masque ne portait pas de masque il puis
l'adopter le masque et il est devenu
il est devenu un masters radical comment
appelle-t-on ça si vous en avez 3 vous
en avez 4 au mieux une paire de lunettes
de protection aussi et portons ça
pendant encore cinq ou six ans mepha
aussi n'a peut-être jamais commis de
plus lourde erreur que quand il a nié le
virus et son origine il est temps pour
l'amérique et le monde de demander
réparation de demander que le parti
communiste chinois prenne ses
responsabilités qui nous devrions tous
déclarés d'une seule voix que la chine
doit payer
ils doivent payer la cdu donald trump
dans le texte mais il faut bien
comprendre que des républicains lui
emboîte le pas et demande aujourd'hui la
démission d'anthony foti notamment des
sénateurs républicains qui estiment que
le scientifique a perdu la confiance du
peuple américain en tout cas cette
hypothèse d'un départ d'anthony fochi
est pour le moment complètement écartée
par la maison blanche qui soutient
fermement le scientifique en lui
accordant toute sa confiance
mais force est de constater qu anthony
fochi est devenu aujourd'hui un symbole
du clivage politique aux états unis et
aussi de la défiance de la parole
officielle en cette période de pandémie